i was on the television show on
showtime's television show shameless a
wonderful show yes and i got um
i mean this was a while ago but it was
exciting to get the audition because
like my parents are deaf as you know
both my parents are deaf super into
hip-hop and like i
like i i was but that's true my parents
are both deaf so i'm fluent in sign
language i grew up you know and i got
the role for this this character it was
the character's name was ruben he was a
deaf crack addicted uh paraplegic former
gay prostitute with aids and i thought
perfect
i thought if
if i don't get this rule there's
something wrong with the hollywood
system
i was like i get i got this role for
sure because i know sign language
there's no way anyone's going to beat me
out for this role but i and i go to the
audition room i sit down it's like all
deaf actors everybody else is a real
deaf man like they're all
they're all the real thing you know what
i mean yeah they're all i mean it's like
if you got a call to like be in like
amistad and you were like yeah a white
boy that's like i'm just really down
with hip-hop i'll get this roll and then
you get there and everybody's like not
here
so i go in and i just i was like oh no
because i thought about because i i went
in i did the audition killed it
no but i
i got the role and i just felt like
guilty because just think about it you
know like you're a deaf here you are
you're a deaf actor yeah you make the
move to hollywood to really commit to
acting already like a a pretty difficult
questionable life choice you know what i
mean like it's already tough you're get
and all you ever get is these auditions
for like sesame street and touched by an
angel and and you know highway to heaven
and if that's been off the air for 25
years but yeah and finally you get a
roll for a showtime show you're like
something media and then this hearing
[ __ ] walks out of the room like how
do you know this sign everybody
i felt i felt bad but i did my time in
the trenches yeah i mean my parents were
deaf i was a sign language interpreter
you're an honorary deaf i am
people are getting weird right now i
don't know why
you you literally this audience
literally has no idea if this is true
but i am i'm like an official yeah
hearing people with deaf parents are
like sort of like kind of like light
deaf you know what i mean like is that
the sign for justifying why you got the
role
but i uh i i was an interpreter for a
long time i mean i i wanted to actually
there's a funny i thought i would i
wanted to show you some of my favorite
signs please just to prove to the
audience it feels weird right now yeah
that i'm i'm the real thing yes
so my my name sign so everybody has a
name sign i thought maybe i'd give you
one at one point but it's m this is m
for m for moshe looks like you're
starting a puppet show
again very disrespectful
that's inframosha so my mom of course
gave me my my name sign so she so she
it was m for moshe because she knew that
i would have a big old dick like she
knew
no it's not it's m for smart it's smart
smart like that it's up here yeah it's
up here oh so she goes like that no no
she's not a marine
she was in the royal navy for the grand
game in islands but she's not a marine
but your
welcome to town i uh
and then i just want to show you some
cool ones like this one this is my
favorite this is reflection
r-e-f-l-e-c-t-i-o-n
reflection right really couldn't it just
be anything as long as you're doing it
thanks dude
isn't
this isn't this hungry well that's
that's actually horny
this is hungry your stomach horny horny
like but you got to do the face
that's i had a stroke that's a totally
different
we have time for one question
you're uh you're a ladies man you're a
ladies man
what is your ratio breaking up to being
broken up with
you want to try that question again
no what uh what i communicated it well
my ratio to breaking how many women have
i broken up with as opposed to being
dumped oh being dumped yeah
no i've never i don't know what that's
what is that
you've never been dumped